[Music]
after the loss of wine enjoy a good
evening ladies and gentlemen it's my
great privilege to be here other buta
night I'm here with my husband who
produced the film we are truly honored
to be the first Mongolians receiving
this prestigious award
I had my MA degree at age of 45 is
firmly enough the same ages student
Academy Awards I really believed it's a
good sign I was right and here today my
daughters are studying at university now
I wanted to have an MA degree before
them to sell my children if you have a
wish Dean ambition you can achieve your
dream whatever you eat as a Mongolian
and grow up in the Gobi I have always
had a burning ambition to introduce the
mesmerizing in harmonic way of nomadic
culture to the world a massive thank you
to the Academy for recognizing honoring
my work and give me the opportunity to
bring Mongolian culture to the world
a huge thank you to my teachers and
classmates of University of
Hertfordshire raucous must have thank
you to my mom dad my husband my family
my wonderful team inclu the friends who
always believed in me
supported all through all my long in
emotional journey
you know enormous thank you to the
nomadic doctor
it was long in all the people of the
village on the shelf for sharing your
beautiful story with us
my teacher director butter who's in
heaven now once told me that if you want
to be filmmaker
you better have a great knowledge about
everything exists on the world and
always must chain yourself to the with
the truth I was this was the key listen
I have been trying to follow I will say
some words in Mongolian in silence to
human issues in mangas or semen wrong
should be dishonest canister how to show
trust your feeling in keep enlightening
to people thank you very much have a
greatly
this Ward is dedicated to my dad who was
a cameraman